à laval on complète la construction de
deux maisons des aînés mais l'île de
montréal n'en n'aura aucune et la
reconstruction d'une demi-douzaine de ch
et celle des vétustes s'embourbe encore
une fois c'est le deux poids deux
mesures on ne fait un budget initial que
je me rappelle bien était de 2.6
milliards on a entrepris la construction
des maisons la maison des aînés ces
projets-là continue à avancer puis nous
à montréal on doit faire les ajustements
pour respecter l'enveloppé globale dans
l'est de montréal 3 ch et celle des très
vétuste de ferme ou change de vocation
c'est le cas de benjamin victor
rousselot dans heureusement le ch et
celle des nicolet dans hochelaga
maisonneuve sera lui carrément fermé et
jeanne le ber sur les terrains de
l'ancien hôpital louis h lafontaine sera
aussi fermée on est en discussion que le
gouvernement par la démolition de jean
delebarre il faut donc reconstruire
trois bâtiments qui compteront 670
chambre en 2021 la facture était évalué
à
450 millions un an plus tard c'est déjà
insuffisant dans des documents obtenus
en vertu de la loi sur l'accès à
l'information la société québécoise des
infrastructures écrit que le budget de
450 millions ne sera plus respecté un
nouvel exercice pour chercher des
réductions de coûts dans le respect des
exigences sera demandée le ciel va faire
ce qu'il peut avec des budgets qui ne
correspondent plus au marché actuel
c'est de contrôler le plus de place
possible avec le budget disponible donc
c'est clair que on a des exercices ça
qu'on essaie d'optimiser juin m car le
nombre des tâches donc en augmentant le
nombre d'otages on comprend qu'on est
capable de faire des économies
donc on est dans ces exercices l'heure
actuelle un défi partout sur l'île le
déficit d'entretien total des ch et
celle des du québec est de 164 millions
mais 60% du total concerne des ch et
celle des de l'est de montréal
le sus de l'ouest de l'île pourrait
aussi fermi 3 ch et celle des trop
vétuste le csld grèce doit inaugurer au
19e siècle ou celui de dorval dont une
partie est centenaire dans l'ouest de
l'île aussi les coûts augmentent on fait
face aux siens surchauffe du marché de
l'immobilier ont fait face à une
surchauffe des coûts de construction
donc le secteur public est affecté au
même titre que tous les autres secteurs
à preuve ce terrain de l'ouest de l'île
de montréal qui devrait accueillir un
nouveau ch et celle des acheté par une
entreprise privée
7,3 millions en avril 2021 il a été
revendu au sus de l'ouest de l'île
10,3 millions sept mois plus tard
construire ou rénover des ch et celle
des est plus cher que jamais alors qu'on
compte maintenant plus de 4000 personnes
qui attendent une place en séries est
celle d un nombre qui grimpe à chaque
année